o lado diz pessoal de quem fala é o dar
que sejam muito bem vindos já mais de um
vídeo e o estrago de que um jogo de tudo
ou os óculos geek é uma coisa que já não
trazia muito tempo a ok pessoal estamos
aqui dentro do jogo eu acho que não
disse o nome do jogo é o de menton forma
pizzoli 2 atenção é eu já sei o episódio
e um está no canal do sol foi o primeiro
jogo em alguns livros que eu joguei e
fui burra é cameron da ecosul esse lobby
é muito antes de dormir eu vou ficar com
uma missão dura agora o gestor o náutico
apresentou não entrou na 16 o android
astronautas este jogo não medo medo ok
uma experiência de horror psicológico eu
não tenho medo nenhum porque isto só
nuvem o que é aquilo média o que é
aquilo a que caiu nas portas do inferno
um ex campeão inter mas não descure que
traz não não quero entrar aqui usei por
interagir com os objetos sobre uma casa
de show talismã minhoca mutantes a
avenida obrigar a banca prontas em faz
sentido temos indícios de morte ao morro
que perdeu a cabeça e o osso da perna
que se chama fé morango assistindo
saberes porque o primeiro na escola isto
quer dizer que há qualquer coisa
escondida no escuro gota faca que está
são partículas de bola no ar agora ser o
pessoal deu tudo errado com instrumentos
e outras três na minha mão eu não tenho
medo é o meu vascão provas quem possui
alguma coisa pelo prêmio meu sangue no
chão uva que morta o opera é só uma
pedra dar calma calma calma
o esqueleto aqui e seguro passar aqui e
assistir uma arma na minha cabeça e eu
num inferno tá tudo termine o pé não tá
preta já pagou a um riso a morrer seu
pai que era lucy eu consigo ver sangue
azul é chavista tipos e se nós estamos à
procura de uma pessoa que está proibida
na sua vida e entretanto também já perdi
porque está um fraquinho labirinto do
rocha gigante
já provei pronto fez a diferença aqui
dentro mas foi em grove
você não acaba aqui dentro 3215 32 15
jatos por aí pode ser algum código para
uma porta não sei mais o que é o filho
da pu não tenho medo não tenho medo eo
tac tac o irmão de oito da emissora o
primeiro eu estava apaixonada e
batimentos completar transmission outra
porta alô alô uma tocha com uma tocha
acho que o aparelho também não sair tem
de ver que alguma coisa machava humala
vem com assim a celeste e branca
conseguiu roubar a alçou o time
inteligente mesmo ok agora abril
excluindo se ouvir outra vez foi o
brilho do maio suposta minutos abriu o
olho não deu o que quer que seja isso
não viu
vamos aproveitar enquanto está ali como
o seu pão como a taiwanesa na frente né
a picape capitalista vai avançar mas há
mais 50 ainda vai achar k nao ha o que
encontrei encontrou mas foi quem gostar
não sabe o trecho vai passar aqui já não
acham não passar aqui porque conseguiu
se safar de homônimo
até que conheceu o aquino pedra de
esgrima inclina ou seja virtual até
agora tem que esperar pelo verde quando
por servir de obra a porta eu acho que
só que ainda assim três pistas da arc
porque senão não sai daqui usava um
hábito que isso abriu no verde abriu no
verde agora leve levi era só isso que
faltava agora extra que esta vai depois
muitos avanços e nada não vai apanhar
porque eu sou cheio de armadilhas ganhou
uma raiva quando era pequeno fazia a
primeira meu caso só não sabe ou não
ainda mais pelo tempo porque na nena na
perna pesa 0 não conseguimos evitar que
alguém é gay mas não consegue mexer meu
está passando não estava aqui algum
citou ela levantou 100
não quero aprender a não conseguir meu
olhar meu está muito legal é um homem
final é um homem problema não é uma
mulher e eu vou estar vai lá primeiro
vai mostrar pós posso ir embora só não é
uma mulher em lojas em pra mim sobre o
caso
anémona não conseguisse uma arma do
coração então é isso só espero que
tenham gostado deste vídeo eu estou
agora vir do futuro porque já este vídeo
e taylor é mesmo o vídeo supostamente ia
ser maior mas como o jogo estava tudo
alagado e só consegui manter estas parte
espero que esteja livre de mesma fique
bem e até a próxima é